bom dia meu nome é gabriel e é um prazer
estar aqui presente
acontece que às vezes a gente está aqui
mas não tá realmente é uma sensação de
que algo falta é como se uma parte nossa
e disse
o movimento é uma novidade e eu pergunto
pra você
se você fosse dá a voz à sua intuição
mais profunda o que você faria se você
pudesse largar tudo por um tempo que
sonho você realizaria em 2011
o meu sonho era dirigia um fusca que
dirigia o fusca em uma viagem de um ano
pelo brasil o famoso um ano sabático
pode parecer estranho mas eu já tive
outros sonhos mais normais como por
exemplo trabalhar no maior acelerador de
partículas do mundo é verdade isso
aconteceu aqui estou no cérebro nesse
laboratório pode não parecer gente mas
eu sou um físico eu fiz mestrado e
doutorado nessa área de física de
acelerador debatidos que a gente chama
de altas energias voltando para 2011
parece os anos 60 não é incrível
em 2011 eu doei as minhas coisas e vende
tudo que eu tinha sobraram duas mochilas
e esse fusca que o carinhosamente
chamava de dorotéia
um belo dia estava eu com a dorotéia
fazer um passeio
passei no posto de gasolina coloquei 20
litros e seguir colina cima até o
momento em que a dorotéia morre
essa subida eu puxei o freio de mão e
dentro ligar de novo e da garra e
entrega da verdade e não pega até o
momento em que encosta um carro atrás e
essa pessoa grita
saia que está pegando fogo
nessa hora eu olho para trás e vejo esse
fogo que estava alto
lembre se não fosse como o motor fica lá
atrás e olha a primeira coisa que eu
faço eu pego o extintor o primeiro
movimento que eu faço eu quebro extinto
o incêndio e vira esse desespero que
você não sabe se você tenta apagar o
fogo ou se você corre porque o negócio
vai explodir e eu sei que os carros
paravam ninguém queria passar do lado
também eventualmente apareceram três
instintos de incêndio ea gente consegue
abrir a lata além do motorista e xixi
apaga dali um segundo povos pode de novo
o tanque de gasolina na frente à
gasolina jorrava atrás e parece que não
tinha nada que a gente fizesse ali que
apagasse aquele fogo até o momento em
que eu me distancio e ficou assistindo
com o coração partido a morte de um ente
querido
por outro lado para a cidade virou um
momento de festa
eu via as pessoas ligando os seus amigos
ou mas quem vem cá meu filho que foi o
que está pegando fogo tais menino virou
um evento na cidade bastante as pessoas
vinham ficavam lá olhando e foi uma
festa até o momento em que o fogo já
dentro do carro começou a derreter o
cabo do freio de mão
imaginem uma subida uma bola de fogo
descendo calculem a probabilidade disso
acabar bem
carros ali embaixo crianças pessoas
eu que nunca fui religioso neste momento
eu rezei eu falei se tem algo aí por
favor que se manifeste que ajude porque
vai dar a largada e não só eu talvez as
outras pessoas que estavam ali presentes
vivenciando aquele momento também de
alguma forma pediram algo fato é que o
desfecho mais improvável acontece o
carro que vinha descendo em linha reta
de repente virou volante e estaciona na
lateral
sem atingir ninguém quando falo
estaciona realmente porque tinha uma
mureta desse tamanho ao longo da pista
em certos momentos ela abria e a
dorotéia estaciona entre essas muletas
sem bater nelas e fica lá então até os
seus últimos suspiros
o fato é que esse evento ele implanta
uma dúvida dentro de mim que é será que
a atenção ea intenção daquelas pessoas
ali presentes daquele evento podem de
alguma maneira ter influenciado o
desdobramento desse evento um lado meu
fala foi um evento de baixíssima
probabilidade mas com muito significado
pessoal e outro lado fala tá mas pode
ter sido coincidência né
pode ter sido mas foi muito estranho
isso o lado fala mas não pode porque
você estaria jogando tudo o que você
aprendeu os seus anos de ciência fora
porque a gente sabe que esse tipo de
fenômeno não pode existir
e aí o que eu faço agora com essa dúvida
volta à cena para 2008
estou em genebra no maior acelerador de
partículas do mundo e foi uma grande
satisfação estar lá foi um sonho que se
realizou
poder ver de perto aquela máquina aquela
complexidade
foi realmente uma experiência muito
incrível poder instalar estava tudo
certo até o momento em que eu estava lá
e eu comecei a sentir um negócio
estranho dentro de mim era uma sensação
que brotava no meu peito e que me falava
que algo estava faltando essa voz essa
intuição e fazer um convite saia da sua
trajetória
te amo a falar siga voz do seu coração
mas e quando a sua intuição fala pra
você fazer algo que é estranho como por
exemplo abandonar essa trajetória que já
era muito bem estabelecida a minha
carreira já estava toda construída já
sabia que ia acontecer pra frente e essa
voz me falava isso foi isso foi tão
intenso foi tão interessante a maneira
como eu senti isso que eu me dei o
direito de experimentar e ver é o que
estava por detrás dessas dessa sensação
então eu volto para o brasil eu termino
o meu doutorado eu passo pelo mercado
financeiro uma experiência que foi
traumático suficiente para não querer
falar nada aqui sobre isso e aí vou
finalmente realizar essa experiência
esse grande sonho de fazer uma viagem de
um ano pelo brasil o que acontece nessa
experiência que você pega um físico
um cara que foi ensinado a pensar ea
controlar e você pega esse cara e larga
ele uma experiência de total liberdade
no brasil
o que acontece então essa experiência
ela foi me convidando a sair desse lugar
de controle que eu estive a minha vida
inteira a melhor analogia que eu posso
fazer pra vocês desse processo é como se
nossa vida a gente estivesse pilotando
uma nave ea gente está aqui agarradinho
no manche a gente morre de medo de
soltar esse negócio se a gente solta
nave vai bater se sabe o que essa viagem
me mostrou é algo totalmente contra
intuitivo é que na verdade quando eu
soltei o manche
parece que assume uma espécie de um auto
piloto e que o negócio se pilota muito
melhor do que a gente consegue querendo
dizer que começaram acontecer essas
experiências de sincronicidade
sincronicidades e tudo isso foi
desafiando o meu sistema de crenças
essa experiência me permitiu então dá um
passo para trás
viver o meu sistema ver a os meus dogmas
ver os meus preconceitos e falando de
preconceito tudo associado com
espiritualidade misticismo estados
alterados de consciência
pra mim antes dessa viagem tudo isso era
coisa de gente maluca que não fazia o
menor sentido
nessa experiência dessa viagem por
experiência direta dessas coisas eu
entendi que a minha arrogância inicial
era fruto de ingenuidade de falta de
experiência então o resumo desse desse
processo é que o voto é entendendo que a
questão da consciência é interessante é
importante e que eu quero investigar
isso
então a primeira coisa que eu descubro é
que existe consciência maior mistério de
todos ninguém entende qual é o mecanismo
por trás
se é realmente o cérebro ou se ela pode
ser algo tão fundamental quanto à
matéria ninguém sabe
pesquisando mais ao descobrir que os
próprios pioneiros da física quântica os
caras que inventaram essa teoria eles
estavam profundamente interessados e
falando sobre assuntos como é
consciência e misticismo
acontece que misticismo é um termo que é
bastante distorcido na nossa cultura a
gente associa com ignorância misticismo
de raiz significa a exploração da
realidade por vias internas tem problema
nenhum de um físico falar disso quando o
cientista busca geralmente as respostas
fora misticismo busca dentro ea questão
é que nos meus anos de formação eu nunca
ouvi falar desses termos dentro da
academia e porque será a minha redenção
veio quando eu descobri esse livro eo
autor e historiador da ciência de casa
conta a história então de qual foi o
processo que aconteceu na ciência é um
processo de pragmatismo ação que
acontece após a segunda guerra mundial
que acontece na segunda guerra mundial é
que o governo norte americano
descobre que o físico é um instrumento
de guerra
o cara faz radar faz bomba atômica que a
gente quer então forma
muitos físicos vejam esse gráfico mostra
o número de doutores antes e depois da
segunda guerra vocês podem ver que tem
uma explosão nesse processo de explosão
não se constrói sete vezes mais
universidades e sim o que se faz é
pragmatismo o curso vamos tirar todas as
questões metafísicas filosóficas que não
constroem nada material gente vai tornar
essas pessoas mais técnicas
esse processo nasce neste momento
herdado e nunca voltou a ser como era
antes
esse foi o desconforto que eu senti na
minha graduação sabia que estava
faltando alguma coisa
pesquisando mais eu descobri a pesquisa
desse norte-americano que chama de
hayden e ele é um pioneiro na nas
pesquisas em que se faz então uma
interface do que a gente já conhece da
física com um ingrediente novo que é a
consciência
o experimento que ele fez que me chamou
muito a atenção é o experimento da fenda
dupla no experimento da fã da dupla a
gente tem uma fonte de luz
essa luz passa por duas aberturas e
depois chega no anteparo
quando ela chega no anteparo ela chega
com essa figura de altos e baixos que a
gente chama de um padrão de
interferência no tempo de entrar em
detalhes nisso eu quero que vocês saibam
só que isso aqui é a padrão os físicos
conhecem bem a novidade aqui é que o bin
laden é traz participantes para entrarem
na sala e atuarem nesse experimento
tentando onde ficará o que está sendo
medido ali através apenas da sua atenção
e intenção
o que é surpreendente é que os
resultados dele e de todos os fãs
bateria de testes que ele fez são
positivas mostram que o fenômeno existe
e o que mais me surpreende é como que
isso não está tocando alarme dentro da
academia como que não tem várias outras
pessoas tentando fazer o mesmo
experimento para ver se isso é realmente
verdade então eu parti pra propor uma
aplicação desse experimento desse ele
entende porque não tem ninguém faz
sendo porque esse tema é um grande tabu
dentro da academia
no meu caso a minha curiosidade é muito
maior do que as dificuldades
eu tenho o prazer de falar pra vocês que
essa pesquisa está em curso agora na
universidade de são paulo é o meu
pós-doutorado no instituto de psicologia
e sob supervisão do professor wellington
sangari e os resultados vão sair agora
neste segundo semestre
é só falar também que essa pesquisa foi
financiada por cláudio fanem tal que
quer dizer que existe um interesse
público enorme em relação a esse tema
eu espero que tenha ficado claro aqui
nessa fala que o meu ponto a tônica
disso aqui é essa é a dúvida é a
curiosidade é a pesquisa investigação é
disso que estou falando
nesse processo de propor essa pesquisa
houveram críticas e críticas dos meus
colegas cientistas
a principal crítica que eu escutei é de
que esse experimento não precisa ser
feito porque já se sabe a resposta de
que nada disso pode existir
agora veja não existe postura -
científica do que é o que o nome disso é
dogma é eu já sei o que eu quero
acreditar não venha me confundir com os
dados que a natureza pode trazer ou não
na ciência isso é um diálogo com a
natureza quintal à martelada final é o
resultado da experiência a gente discute
sobre os resultados
quando você tenta interromper uma
pesquisa antes de ela ser feita tem algo
muito contraditória e normalmente essas
pessoas se dizem os defensores da razão
mais pura realmente é bastante
contraditório
honestamente até agora eu não escutei
uma boa razão para eu não fazer essa
pesquisa
na verdade e são ótimos os argumentos
para se fazer
o primeiro é se a gente realmente
entendi essa anomalia e se confirma que
isso está acontecendo nesse experimento
existe isso é uma anomalia no maria
historicamente são portas de entrada
para novas teorias novos conhecimentos
se isso se confirma é o impacto é enorme
a nossa cultura a maneira como a gente
se organiza tudo o que a gente acredita
história que a gente conta dos nossos
filhos
tudo se transforma só isso já é um ótimo
motivo
o segundo motivo é que o tema é de
grande interesse do público
não existe uma civilização que já passou
por esse planeta que não alega ter
passado experimentado é fenômenos
anômalos eu tô falando de telepathe a de
clarividência de pré cognição e
psíquicos inese pesquisas mostram que
mais de 90% dos brasileiros já passaram
alegam ter passado por essas
experiências
então me parece muito honesto trazer um
retorno ao público que são as pessoas
que pagam o salário dos cientistas é um
assunto que é da sua demanda que é do
seu interesse
finalmente é eu acho que já passou da
hora dos cientistas perderem o ter o
medo em relação a essa temática e
derrubar esse tabu para que se possa
investigar isso de maneira livre pra que
a gente entenda quais são as nossas
reais capacidades
quais são os limites da consciência
obrigado pela sua atenção
[Aplausos]